there are reports that progress is made
on the battlefield both in terms of
territory in terms of casualties
including the senior leadership is that
progress reflected in the outflow of
Westerners both Americans and Europeans
going to Syria to fight on behalf of
Islamic state yes there is a reduction
but it's not shut off all together there
are still people going there
there are less spiders though than there
were previously
we are taking
increasingly more effective steps to
curb the travel to affect the decisions
that people are making we have now many
communications centers that are
beginning to reach out to the world of
to Islam to counter the false narrative
of ISIL and present to people what the
realities are on the ground just the
other day 15 members of ISIL were
executed in Iraq up and we
because they were trying to get out or
they were not you know buying the
narrative this is what happens if you
try to get out will kill you
and effect you're a prisoner of this
we see increasing instances of fighters
trying to desert or running away from
their fighting positions even as
commanders are urging them to fight so
we believe we're making progress it's
still Isis is still a danger it still
has people that has positioned in
countries over the last few years and
it's something that's going to have to
continue to require our vigilance and
our initiative for some period of time
but we are going to defeat and destroy
Isis left one of the things you point to
is the effective use appears to affect
use of social media
by Islamic state what are we doing to
counter that how do we measure progress
on that bar that
well it's a very great question because
we've been evolving in our understanding
of the metrics of how you do better but
we have an increasingly effective group
of centers in Abu Dhabi for instance in
the Emirates they've opened a center
which is staffed by arab-speaking
clerics communicators people who get on
the social media and actively counter
the false narrative of ISIL the Saudi
Arabians are opening a major center
which will draw religious leaders from
around the world to help speak about the
true Islam
it is a fact that ISIL mastered an early
presentation in the social media that
was encountered initially
now it is being countered and
increasingly I think people are learning
more
about the lives on which their false
Caliphate is based a different part of
the battlefield in the wake of the
attacks in Paris English recently
Brussels some people have been concerned
there hasn't been adequate coordination
and cooperation among European security
authorities what's being done to improve
that situation a great deal of work is
being done even before the Brussels
attacks came in
we had a team called a foreign fighter
surge team that had gone to Brussels to
work with erith or
to try to examine where there may be
some gaps of where we needed to do
better
we've had a number of meetings were
scheduled again before the attacks for
this month in which our experts are
going to work with
but one of the things Europeans to do
and we've talked with this
they must begin to do a passenger
system on air flights travel and they
need to have an early access screening
system for some of those folks so that
we can do a better job Europe has not
been with rest of certainly the United
States is and other countries with
respective that tracking and
had privacy concerns we respect them but
I think they're learning as we did in
America
that you have to take certain
precautions and you have to give up a
little something to be safer
does that lacking on Europe's part
close a potential security threat in the
United States because people can come
from Europe to the United States you
having the track sufficiently in Europe
in Europe I'm talking about yep at all
but the what extent does that pose a
threat to the United States because you
have security problems in Europe that
can be exported essentially to our
shores well yes but we have want to talk
to screen is a much more it's much
harder to get across the pond as we say
and get into the United States than it
is to move from Syria in the Europe